11 million followers on Tik Tok because
of you because I I went there 5 years
ago I was making unlimited content
saying go to Tik Tok go to Tik Tok go to
Tik Tok but this is me talking to a
friend this is an actual conversation
I'm like you had 500,000 followers on
Instagram and that made you feel good
and even though you knew me and know
I've always been right about this [__]
you didn't have the humility to move to
Tik Tok and start at zero because you
were just nice and comfortable heer the
fact that you did and the fact that so
many kids that intimately know me and
follow me blindly and fans that I'm
friends with and acquaintances all of
them held on and didn't want to speaks
to curiosity all those people are one
person they should have been able to
move like this Comfort is not good